(pensive music)
- We are headed up to the
northern part of Israel
where residents around
these areas are very worried
about ongoing Hezbollah attacks.
(siren ringing)
The people that we're meeting
around here are saying
that in the past week, there's
been more and more risk,
more and more people that
are leaving the city.
(Avihay speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)
So right now, we're at Kibbutz Hagoshrim
where people have come
from all around the
community to prepare food
for the Israeli soldiers.
- It's important for them
to have like something,
even for once a day,
something good to eat
and to see other people
and to see the civilians
do all this stuff.
- The people here are
saying by cooking food
for the soldiers and
just trying to help out,
it's easing the tension of being so close
to the potential fighting
that's all around them.
- Yesterday we had a alarm here
and we had all of us and
more people in this place.
It's not very safe.
We get used to the bombs here, yeah.
There is no other option,
except for winning this war, I think.
And this is what we feel here.
So we do whatever we
can to raise the morale.
(dramatic music)
- So just now,
the mayor received an
evacuation order for the city.
That means all the residents here
are gonna be asked to leave.
They're gonna organize
buses to bring people out.
- The government decided
that all the citizens
who live five kilometer
from the border will
evacuate more souther.
(Avihay speaking in foreign language)
(Kiryat speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)
- [Ben] The border with
Lebanon is just right
across this mountain
here, and the worry is
as this war continues to drag
on and escalate that Hezbollah
in the north in Lebanon
could easily make a crossing
into this area the same way
that Hamas made a crossing.
(Avihay speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)